if India and China are wealthy that's
great Adam Smith said you don't want
poor neighbors you want wealthy
neighbors hi I'm Ted baliker with reason
TV and today I'll be speaking with
Professor Joyce Appleby Appleby is a
historian at UCLA her most recent book
is the relentless revolution a history
of capitalism let's talk about the title
it's the the relentless revolution why
did you title it that way because
capitalism produces a relentless
revolution as we can tell by reading The
Economist every week or picking up the
New York Times or a recent magazine I'm
sure that there's constant change
because as I insist in my book that
capitalism is really a cultural system
based on an entrepreneurial economy it
impinges on everything in a society he's
got a voracious appetite for money but
energy and talent and and innovation and
this is very disruptive of settled ways
and that's one of the recurring themes
in the book is this idea that there is
an upheaval that harms people and then
progress later on can you address that
we had the agrarian revolution the
industrial revolution as you call it and
I didn't I said it wouldn't catch on
we're trying what's right both the
agricultural changes and the industrial
ones are more evolved and then produced
a revolution they are absolutely
essential developments for capitalism to
emerge because as I said you have
capitalist practices but you don't have
capitalism until the economy dominates
political thinking provides people the
new vocabulary for talking about change
inspires new social values so that
people don't want to do the same thing
that their grandparents did but accept
innovation and change and you said that
commerce alone is not capitalism no
commerce as old as Hammurabi you know
it's been around for millennia and and
merchants stayed within their place in
society basically aristocratic societies
but capitalism couldn't keep its pace
because it involved people
took laborers to produce for capitalism
so it could not contend itself with a
little interstitial space in society it
had to come to dominate because it had
to change laws it had it free up market
exchanges and the like and this took
political power so capitalism has this
propulsive force that Commerce alone
does not you talk about capitalism being
rooted in culture and not just an
economic process as a lot of people
think of it and changing minds changing
habits I think one of the interesting
points was the idea that in pre
capitalist society famines weren't
necessarily something to be fixed right
it was just sort of the way could you
expect that because that seems so
strange to us today could you explain
that mindset well yes I think that in
the traditional society they had one of
the reasons they had Christians that
endured is because everything remained
the same the only variations you had
actually were agricultural harvest good
years brought prosperity maybe a little
more spending little fuller stomachs bad
years but belt-tightening often famines
but everything repeated itself and
because it repeated itself it just
seemed like this was the way it was
supposed to be and what about now in the
21st century everybody is you know
sometimes there's a lot of talk today
about whether America is is in decline
there's a lot of press about China
having the second-biggest economy now
although ours is still vastly bigger you
you touch on some of the reforms in the
in the 1990s that India implemented to
get rid of the license raj all these
kind of Byzantine restrictions red tape
since the history of capitalism seems to
be you know there's a new country right
around the corner what do you think the
future will bring now you know I'm a
Nestorian I'm a lot better explaining
the past and I ever predicted the future
was gonna be a futurist man right I have
great confidence in America I think it
has real problems
challenges I think we're going through
an awfully bad patch now I think our
politics now are kind of preventing us
having an industrial policy and doing
many of the things that we ought to be
doing but I cannot believe we won't do
it and I think if India and China are
wealthy that's great Adam Smith said you
don't want poor neighbors you want
wealthy neighbors the more wealth there
is in the world the better off it is for
everyone not only in a sense of personal
lives but just in the growth of the
economy of innovation perhaps getting to
a point where we have a great deal more
leisure in the world
that's such a important point I think
because I think a lot of people have the
mindset of like this is some global you
know football game or war something that
if we ascend that means someone else
drops the zero-sum pie has never applied
to a capitalist economy it's never been
a zero-sum prize always expanding and
what about public opinion in in how
people view capitalism these days if you
look at recent polls even in the United
States if you ask people what do you
think about capitalism it gets mixed
reviews what do you make of that I don't
think that the criticism goes very deep
because there isn't a conspicuous
alternative and that's a good point how
would capitalism stack up against
competing systems well I think it
stacked up pretty well against competing
systems I mean I know people who are
unhappy about the economy are kind of
horrified when you say that I think that
we're as I say I think we're in a very
bad patch I think it's terrible that you
have the income inequality and the drop
in income that we've seen and a decline
in social mobility that we've seen in
the United States in the last 20 30
years those are serious problems and I'm
not minimizing them but I all it takes
is political will to solve those
problems you have an interesting line I
think exploitation is not exclusively
capitalist but wealth creation is can
you explain that well people say a
capitalism exploitative and of course
that's what March do well done because
there were horrible conditions and
factories in the 19th century in in the
world today there are
but the exploitation in traditional
societies was just dreadful
so the the peasantry was treated with
contempt peasant daughters were seen as
just the natural sexual partners of the
aristocracy I mean people who think that
capitalism is the major exploitative
system simply don't know very much about
the Middle Ages or the 14th or 15th 16th
centuries and the reason I contrast this
with wealth generating is because this
is what capitalism is done we're in this
building because of capitalism they
didn't have buildings like this that
didn't have information technology they
didn't have the University of California
so you can't you can separate the good
from the bad
but they are kind of linked together if
you want this level of enjoyment of
science the arts entertainment food
transportation information etc then you
have to be recognized what's generating
the wealth to produce it
Iridessa tea with
teachers tried to educate me on as well
lucky